[Music]
I'm the best remember sustained Kenya my
goal is to be the best favorite lifter
okay
Natasha is my daughter and they're best
friends
[Music]
my name is Matthew Mira I do 850
my name is your seven-day vehicles they
also do weightlifting my elder brother
was a weak lifter and there is Joe
company into the gym just in 1999 there
were no women resistance so they were
asking the ladies to come in Jane and
that's how I joined and we never looked
back
I associate with lifting when I was 11
years old I used to go with my mom to
the gym whenever she was training at the
gym we do many exercises we have squat
the deadlift bench presses shoulder
press do back extensions when it comes
to drink those conditioning exercises to
us laugh at our energy future
haha I've competed in four Commonwealth
Games for allAfrica games for African
Championships and in one Olympic Games
Natacha one day is going to be Who I am
natasha is a strong lady I can say that
that's why I even thought that I should
introduce her to the spot and motivate
her and push her to be even better than
me and become the top lifter in Kenya
what makes me proud of my mom is that
she stands out from the rest and she's a
strong woman I wanted to be a lifter
because my mother she has fed me always
and she told me from the first day that
I can make it I can do it
[Music]
my mom is amazing person yeah Lilith we
all agree with curry new phone
jenika Shenyang in Rosario Vargas are a
mother and daughter separated by a
border one living in San Diego and the
other in Mexico
I came from Mexico 2006 because I want
to get another opportunities for my cats
cuando se bueno
Encino me despedida ya pensa came it was
la vie de la Volpe rubbish
I don't have the permission to cross the
border the line from the last
year-and-a-half I see my mom to the
fence at the sight of a by National Park
in San Diego the u.s. Border Patrol
allows families to meet on the weekends
loved ones enter the park and walk
directly up to the border a steel fence
this gives families on both sides a rare
opportunity to see and speak to each
other
no veo el Circo apart a Mira tristeza
made Alegria porque voy a vera mija you
know you're gonna see your mom
you're gonna see your family but the
fans and they have a tiny holes in my
mom sometimes put the finger in the 10
yo I just a little touch it just touch
it or sometimes I give a kiss
esta muy cerca a la vez tan lejos for my
family in sympathy with Akira mucho on
April 30th for the third time ever
authorities agree to open the door
allowing select families a brief moment
to embrace each of them will only have
three minutes
boys are not come home a bias until our
momento take it up with our Asajj they
get wasted who died right now I feel so
happy because I'm waiting I'm waiting so
much this moment
[Music]
[Music]
I feel incredible she was so happy she
was so sweet with me she tell me I love
you mommy I love you so much I love you
love you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
police say the shots came from one or
more vehicles over 1200 shooting to the
city so far this year it's time for
someone to step up and stop them advisor
[Music]
Inglewood is historically one of the
worst neighborhoods in the city of
Chicago and also in the entire United
States of America there have been
children murdered while sleeping in
their beds because bullets penetrated
the walls while they were sleeping
Inglewood is generally a place where no
one feels safe what brought me to the
corner of 75th and Stewart was a young
lady was murdered her name was Lucille
Barnes she was 34 and she was a mother
and she was just trying to break up a
fight and she was killed in a drive-by I
didn't know her but I was outraged and I
felt like at this point if mothers are
being murdered something has to be done
some people thought that it was too
dangerous to go and sit on a corner in a
place where someone had just been
murdered three days before we went out
we put on pink t-shirts and we went and
sat on the corner we got some hot dogs
and we fed people we talked to people
more importantly we gave out a lot of
hugs so we got together these moms who
have the time and who had the passion
for it and I felt that you know being
there and being a present and having
eyes on the street and eyes on the
children that it would interrupt and it
would prevent a lot of stuff that could
potentially happen while you're doing
that you're playing a game with a kid
that you may never get to play with we
want them to grow up together so that
when they're older they're not enemies
and they're not targets of one another
they're not shooting or killing each
other since we posted up on the corner
of 75th and Stewart
there have been no shootings on that
block no shootings no murders there
hasn't even been as much as a fistfight
there's a sense of hope that they didn't
have before it all because were mothers
and you don't want to underestimate the
power of the mother
[Music]
Mother's Day the one day a year are
people all over the world paid tribute
to mom ma mom or ma but how did it all
begin enter Anna Jarvis the founder of
Mother's Day who came to despise her own
holiday Anna Jarvis really really loved
her mother her mother dies in 1905 and
in 1907 she really starts this campaign
that we need to have a day in honor of
what mothers do
let's dr. Katherine and Shalini she's an
historian and wrote a book about Anna
she always identified herself as an ATAR
vez the founder of Mother's Day and in
1914 after six years and state-by-state
campaigning Jarvis's dream came true
President Woodrow Wilson officially
designated a second Sunday of May as
Mother's Day
hooray right
Jarvis felt Wilson was taking credit for
her efforts and he wasn't the only
source of her ire Anna had a really
wonderful enemies list she was mad at
the candy industry and she was mad at
the floor industry she was mad at all
these charities she also turned in some
of her early allies including John
Wanamaker a business tycoon who saw a
commercial opportunity and Mother's Day
he started putting the holiday on
everything even dishes at his restaurant
Jarvis did not approve
she ordered this mother stay solid and
once the Sal arrived mrs. Jarvis has
dumped it on the floor and walked out
that was not what the day was supposed
to be what exactly was the day supposed
to be so it really wasn't meant to be go
out rush off buy all these flowers and
greeting cards and candy and gifts it
was just go home and spend the day with
your mother that's all she wants I
wonder what ana Jarvis would say about
the way Mother's Day celebrated today
she would still be defending it against
commercialization we celebrate this
holiday in ways that she doesn't think
we should he was that people don't
forget about Anna Jarvis the mother of
Mother's Day and please send your mama
card
for her a greeting card would be
insincere it would be cheap it would be
lazy if you can't go home
then you know write a letter to her
don't just send a card got it right your
mama handwritten letter she deserves it
do what you think it is the ultimate
eternal tribute to your first love your
mom
the I love mom heart tattoo iconic and
below
[Music]
the history of the imam centric tribute
dates back to the 1700s when sailors
were at the forefront of tattoo culture
picture this you're staring down a long
stint at sea possibly to never return
home these said sailors often wanted to
keep their loved ones close and what
could be any closer than a heart on your
arm
this heart could symbolize the heart of
a girlfriend a wife or mom it is even
said that mom can symbolize a love of
country the motherland if you will but
nothing says I love mom
like this guy Norman Collins aka sailor
Jerry sailor Jerry is the man who
popularized in polarised I love mom
tattoo amongst many others nowadays I
love mom tattoos are as popular as ever
amongst those in the service and
civilians though the imagery has changed
a bit the heartfelt sentiment remains
the same we love you mom
[Music]